[Music]
I'm not sick when I run like I'm really
I'm just so normal
you wouldn't think someone who goes
unconscious like 14 times a day runs
like you just wouldn't put it that way
[Music]
my name is Katie cook I'm 20 years old I
live in Dublin Ireland and I love
running I was dying
there's four two types of epilepsy -
nine years old a one of which which is
frontal lobe epilepsy so at the moment I
have 14 seizures in the 24-hour period
they used to be 1617 so we're coming
down slightly which is why I was getting
really bad dizziness from my medicine
- and into the hospital and they loaded
me which is a term for epileptics when
you're going on like a new medicine and
I didn't wake up until 6 days later I
was a mobile for the goths up 2 years I
moved from being in a wheelchair to
being in the same her frame when I
gradually started getting back into
running it kinda gave me this newfound
energy I don't know why I put on my
ready boots and started running I feel
like it's so cliched but you kind of
feel like on top of the world that you
could do anything like I don't feel sick
anymore until I have a seizure of I
don't like Damas you know it's amazing
feeling like all the endorphins like
pulsing her your body and it's great
like I like it's honestly like amazing I
train alone for most Myron's
like during the week however I do have a
pal for my races like official races
which is dr. Colin tardy
[Music]
so I have two roles so first of all I'm
her doctor
the other role I play which is to be her
partner in running and my job is to make
sure that when katie has a seizure if
she's running that nobody carts her off
the course nope
the seizure so before I knew Katie she
would run races and if they were in
public people would you know quite
reasonably insists that she be carried
off the course which to her displeasure
so my job is to say no you know that I
am her doctor and that she's fine that
she'll recover
and then she gets up and she runs I
don't let anything really get in the way
of living life at all I just don't think
it's the way to go I suppose yeah I
don't I don't let epilepsy get in the
way at all
[Music]
you